THEIR SPACE IN CIVIC LIFE.
A HANDFUL OF WOMEN STAND QUIETLY
BUT DEFIANTLY.
THEY ARE HERE TO PROTEST THE
TALIBAN'S DE FACTO BAN ON GIRLS
GOING TO SCHOOL AFTER FIFTH
GRADE.
A SMALL ACT OF GREAT COURAGE.
TALIBAN FIGHTERS START TO POUR
IN.
THEY ARE HEAVILY ARMED.
A MENACING QUESTION NEWARK.
A NEW ARRIVAL APPEARS UNSURE OF
WHETHER TO GET OUT OF THE CAR.
FOR A MOMENT IT SEEMS THE
TALIBAN MAY HAVE COME TO PROTECT
THE WOMEN.
BUT THE ILLUSION IS QUICKLY
SHATTERED.
SOMEONE FROM THE TALIBAN HAS
JUST COME IN TELLING EVERYONE TO
PUT AWAY THEIR CAMERAS.
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE TENSE OVER
THERE.
A PHONE RIPPED OUT OF A WOMAN'S
HANDS.
THEY SHOVE JOURNALISTS BACK.
WE TRY TO KEEP FILMING, BUT THE
TALIBAN DON'T WANT THE WORLD TO
SEE.
>> THEY ARE RIPPING THE WOMEN'S
POSTERS.
PUT IT WAY.
>> A MACHINE GUN BURST SENDS A
CLEAR MESSAGE.
THE PROTEST IS OVER.
HE IS THE HEAD OF THE TALIBAN'S
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES IN KABUL
AND THE WOMEN DID NOT HAVE
PERMISSION TO PROTEST.
WHY DOES A SMALL GROUP OF WOMEN
ASKING FOR THEIR RIGHT TO BE
EDUCATED THREATEN YOU SO MUCH?
>> I RESPECT WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
I RESPECT HUMAN RIGHTS, HE SAYS.
IF I DIDN'T RESPECT WOMEN, YOU
WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE.
>> Reporter: WOULD YOU HAVE
GIVEN THEM PERMISSION IF THEY
ASKED FOR IT?
>> YES, OF COURSE, HE SAYS.
WE WOULD HAVE.
BUT PERMISSIONS ARE ILLUSIVE AND
PREVIOUS PROTESTS HAVE MET A
SIMILAR FATE.
ON THE STREETS, THE CONSEQUENCES
OF ONE RECENT DEMONSTRATION CAN
STILL BE SEEN.
AT ALMOST EVERY BEAUTY SALON,
IMAGES OF WOMEN'S FACES HAVE
BEEN DEFACED AS IF TO ERASE THEM
FROM PUBLIC LIFE COMPLETELY.
THE WOMEN INSIDE THIS SALON ARE
TOO SCARED TO APPEAR ON CAMERA.
>> HI!
HOW ARE YOU?
>> Reporter: I ASK THEM ABOUT
THE POSTERS OUTSIDE.
WHO DID IT?
>> TALIBAN.
>> Reporter: THE TALIBAN DID IT?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: THE TALIBAN CAME
AND DROVE AWAY THE PROTESTERS.
THEN THEY CURSED US AND SAID TO
REMOVE THE POSTERS, THEY TELL
ME.
THEY TOLD US TO PUT ON A BURQA
AND SIT IN OUR HOMES.
BUT THIS CITY IS FULL OF BRAVE
WOMEN LIKE HER WHO REFUSE TO DO
THAT.
THE MOTHER OF FIVE SAYS SHE WAS
FORCED TO BECOME A TAXI DRIVER
WHEN HER HUSBAND WAS MURDERED A
YEAR AGO LEAVING BEHIND HIS CAR,
BUT LITTLE ELSE.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
LIFE HAS CHANGED SINCE THE
TALIBAN TOOK POWER.
>> A LOT OF CHANGES.
TOO MANY.
I AM SORRY.
>> Reporter: IT'S OKAY.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
IT'S OKAY.
>> Translator: SINCE THE TALIBAN
REGIME HAS COME TO POWER, IT HAS
BECOME VERY DIFFICULT.
>> Reporter: SHE OFFERS TO TAKE
US FOR A RIDE.
IT'S ANOTHER SMALL ACT OF
COURAGEOUS RESISTANCE.
THE TALIBAN HAD NOT OFFICIALLY
BANNED WOMEN FROM DRIVING, SHE
SAYS SHE HAS RECEIVED THREATS
AND THAT THE MILITANTS HIT HER
CAR TWO WEEKS AGO AS A WARNING.
I SEE THE MEN.
THEY STARE AT YOU.
THEY LOOK AT YOU.
IT'S NOT LONG BEFORE SHE PICKS
UP A FARE.
USUALLY SHE PREFERS TO TAKE
WOMEN AND STAY IN AREAS SHE IS
FAMILIAR WITH.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE RISKS THAT
YOU'RE TAKING WHEN YOU GO OUT
EVERY DAY AND DO YOUR WORK?
>> Translator: YES, YES, IN SOME
PLACES WHERE I SEE TALIBAN
CHECKPOINTS, I'M FORCED TO GO
THROUGH A STREET OR CHANGE MY
ROUTE.
BUT I ACCEPTED THIS RISK FOR THE
SAKE OF MY CHILDREN.
>> Reporter: ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF TOWN AN ENGLISH TEACHER IS
ALSO WORKING HARD TO GIVE HER
STUDENTS A BETTER FUTURE.
THE PAST YEAR HAS NOT BEEN EASY.
IN MAY, A HORRIFIC BOMBING
TARGETED THE SCHOOL WHERE SHE
TEACHES, TAKING MORE THAN 80
INNOCENT LIVES.
SO YOU WERE HERE WHEN THE
EXPLOSIONS HAPPENED?
>> YES, I WAS IN FRONT OF THE
DOOR.
>> Reporter: YOU WERE IN FRONT
OF THE DOOR?
DID YOU SEE IT WITH YOUR OWN
EYES?
>> I SAW A VERY HUGE EXPLOSION
IN FRONT.
OTHER DOOR.
>> Reporter: INCREDIBLY, THE
SCHOOL REOPENED, BUT WEEKS LATER
THE TALIBAN SWEPT TO POWER AND
ANNOUNCED THAT FOR THE TIME
BEING FROM 6th THROUGH 12th
GRADE, ONLY BOYS SHOULD COME TO
SCHOOL.
IT'S JUST VERY STRIKING THAT A
BOMB WAS NOT ABLE TO STOP THESE
GIRLS COMING TO SCHOOL.
NOW THE TALIBAN HAS BEEN ABLE TO
STOP THEM FROM COMING TO SCHOOL.
>> YES, IT'S TRUE.
EVERY DAY I SEE TALIBAN IN THE
STREETS.
I BECOME -- I BE AFRAID.
>> Reporter: BUT YOU ARE STILL
COMING EVERY DAY, YOU ARE STILL
TEACHING?
>> YES, WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
IT'S JUST THE THING THAT WE CAN
DO FOR OUR CHILDREN, FOR OUR
DAUGHTERS, FOR OUR GIRLS.
>> Reporter: IN THE 5th GRADE
CLASSROOM THE GIRLS ARE EXCITED
TO TEST THEIR ENGLISH SKILLS.
>> HI!
>> I WANT YOU TO RAISE YOUR HAND
IF YOU LOVE SCHOOL.
WOW!
EVERYBODY LOVES SCHOOL.
>> Reporter: THIS MAY WELL BE
THE LAST YEAR THEY GET TO COME
AND STUDY, YET THEY ARE STILL
FULL OF HOPE FOR THE FUTURE.
RAISE YOUR HAND TO TELL ME WHAT
YOU WANT TO BE WHEN YOU GROW UP.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO BE?
>> DOCTOR.
>> Reporter: DOCTOR?
OKAY.
WHO ELSE WANTS TO BE A DOCTOR?
OH, WOW.
A LOT OF DOCTORS.
16-YEAR-OLD SANAM USED TO HAVE
DREAMS, TOO.
SHE WANTED TO BE A DENTIST.
THE EXPLOSION AT HER SCHOOL LEFT
HER WITH SERIOUS INJURIES, BUT
SHE WAS BRAVE ENOUGH TO GO BACK
FOR THE SAKE SHE, SHE SAYS, OF
HER CLOSE FRIEND WHO COULD NOT.
>> Translator: I FELT THAT I
MUST GO BACK AND STUDY FOR THE
PEACE OF HER SOUL.
I MUST STUDY AND BUILD MY
COUNTRY SO THAT I CAN MAKE HER
WISHES AND DREAMS COME TRUE.
>> Reporter: RIGHT NOW YOU
CANNOT GO TO SCHOOL.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> Translator: I FEEL ALL MY
DREAMS ARE CRUSHED AND BURIED.
FOR I WON'T BE ALLOWED TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND STUDY.
ALL MY MOTIVATION IS COMPLETELY
GONE.
>> Reporter: IT'S OKAY.
TAKE A MINUTE.
IT'S OKAY.
IF YOU WANT TO STOP, WE CAN
STOP.
IT'S OKAY.
>> Translator: NO.
THE TALIBAN ARE THE PEOPLE WHO,
THEY ARE THE CAUSE OF THE
SITUATION I AM IN RIGHT NOW.
MY SPIRIT IS GONE.
MY DREAMS ARE BURIED.
>> Reporter: AND YET RECENTLY
SHE HAS STARTED TO READ HER
BOOKS AGAIN AND STUDY A LITTLE
BIT EVERY DA